hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the fiji world cup 2021 it's
youngsheest of duda versus sergey
karjakin and this is their second game
of the classical time format the first
one we didn't show is a really really
quick draw uh karjakin messed something
up in the opening and he had to go for a
repetition of moves and now duda has the
white pieces and it's uh well it's quite
an impressive game especially for the
finals of such a huge event as the fiji
world cup so without further ado let's
check it out and see what happened duda
with the white pieces opens with d4 we
have knight to f6 by sergey c4 e6 knight
to f3 and d5 uh so a normal queen's
gambit declined knights to c3 and c5 now
going for the semitaj defense we have c
captures uh c captures uh and now queen
captures on d4 we have e captures on d4
and now bishop to g5 so nothing out of
the ordinary this has all been played
before uh bishop to e7 preparing the
castle and e3 duda also preparing bishop
e2 castling and so on so here we have
castles by uh sergey and now bishop to
e2 is the most common move herein does
make sense you want to develop the
bishop you want to castle your king to
safety but he did not go for that he
played rook to d1 and this uh is uh well
sort of a very very complicated game uh
that's been played once in a kind of a
top tier game uh some 10 years ago but
we're we're gonna get to that uh so the
black king remains in the center a
little bit longer white will still need
at least two moves to castle uh we have
knights to c6 attacking the white queen
and queen to a4 and now bishop to e6
adding another defender to the d5 pawn
and now bishop to b5 so now white is
ready to castle
but black plays bishop to b6 so let's
see
what what white can do here in the game
that we mentioned that was played some
10 years ago it was played in 2011 uh
between anish giri and yu wang uh and uh
well anish won that game by castling in
this position but it was a blitz game
this is a classical game and duda goes
for the well uh strongest move
recommended by the engine and that is
bishop captures on f6 so no doubt uh he
has this very well prepared uh bishop
captures on f6 and now he goes for the
pawn knight captures on d5 it's not a
problem if black wants to and always
recapture on b2 and this is exactly what
karjakin will do so bishop captures with
rook captures and the bishop captures on
b2 now saying okay i might go bishop to
c3 check next uh to mess up your
castling privileges but duda
does not go for castles here duda plays
king to e2
sort of keeping the king in the center
of the board uh saying that if a queen
trade occurs at any moment i will have
already a very nicely centralized king
and rook to d1 is coming rook h to d1 so
both of my rooks will already very
nicely be controlling the d file so
bishop back to f6 by uh karjakin and now
rook h to d1 sort of artificially
castling rook ate the c8 and now bishop
to c4
we have queen to b4 offering a queen
trade thinking that this will uh will
probably be another draw and then we're
going to go into the tie breaks and to
do that place queen to b3 now he says
okay we can trade queens but we trade on
b3 uh so sergey trades here we have
capris captures and now knight to b8
shifting the knight uh over to
the other side of the board uh you could
also trade off everything with something
like rook here as the bishop guards that
square but he decided to reshuffle the
knight and now duda starts his attack
and he plays g4 and it's uh already very
unpleasant g5 is coming and this bishop
does not have a lot of squares so here
we have h6 stopping g5 now comes h4 uh
we have g6 and now g5 captures captures
and bishop to e7 now and now rook to e5
going after this bishop here uh we have
knight to c6 defending the bishop and
attacking the rook and now comes the
move that uh will really gives uh black
a lot of trouble but i will not just
show it to you feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the absolute
best move for duda here while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
well
not going for a material idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's rook to d7 going after the
seventh rank just giving up the exchange
like this and if black goes for the
exchange let's say knight captures an e5
we're gonna capture on e5 and now the
bishop is under attack and if the bishop
moves we have a triple attack on the f7
pawn not only that we're also
threatening knight captures and g6
because the f7 pawn is pinned so uh
black is very limited in his responses
here so he could play some like bishop
g5
but then we just played knight captures
on f7 threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and there's no way for black
to get out of this you can't go here the
knight covers this if you go here then
you go under the mask of the rook so uh
you you have to capture the knight so
rook captures rook captures and now
again you're threatening a lot of very
nasty discoveries here you're gonna have
to sidestep this and then we'll capture
some b7 uh and uh well uh white is white
will be winning this there's no way for
for the black king to activate itself
and the d spawns are now just marching
forward so that's one way to do it but
after rook to d7 uh karjakin decided to
go bishop to d8 and now comes rook to b5
so
what do you play here it's a it's a very
tricky position this rook wants to
capture on b7 then you're going to have
a triple attack on f7 and there is not a
lot you can do yeah of course the b6 is
one option and it is very much playable
but the idea is if b6 then we're going
to go knight to e5 and then after knight
captures we're going to play rook
captures and again it's a very very
tough position to play for black not a
lot
to go for here uh you can all uh the
problem is if this is hanging there's a
lot of pressure on the king side and if
you try something like rook to c7 to
guard to this and try and trade
everything off uh there's always a
bishop captures an f7 that's the problem
and now if rook captures we can pick up
the bishop on d8 and the white will have
a great position here
but in the game knight the a5 was played
b6 was kind of better than knight to the
a5 and now the position is completely
winning but duda decides not to win it
right away here you could i mean
everyone sees it for some reason duda
decided to go for a different sort of
idea uh rook capture san diego removing
the defender of the knight uh clearly uh
wins captures captures and captures now
bishop and knight for a rook uh but duda
decided against this for some reason he
played bishop to d5 first uh now okay
adding a third attacker to the to the b7
uh pawn also nicely controlling the the
knight here so the knight doesn't really
have a way of entering the game uh but
now we have rook to c7 and now uh
basically the same idea applies but just
in case you've missed it feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
duda while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not uh falling uh
for for the idea of rook capture 78
because this doesn't work and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's bishop captures on f7 uh but just
in case you were wondering this doesn't
work now even though it seems like
you're going to have some discoveries
here uh because of rook captures now
attacks the bishop on d5 rook captures
on a5 and now we play b6 and we kick
away the defender of the bishop rogue b5
we're going to play this and now you
have to either move the rook and then
lose the bishop or better yet maybe grab
two pawns captures captures and then
captures and play this game but it's
very unlikely that you will be
able to to win this so instead bishop
captures an f7 is much much better now
if rook captures then we capture on d8
with check and after king king goes here
we're going to capture on a5 and now
we're up a whole night of course this is
completely winning uh so after bishop
captures an f7 and karjakin played king
to g7 and now we have rook calculus on
c7 bishop captures uh ending now we have
bishop to d5 and it was in this position
on move 30 that sergey karjakin resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here
even though materially black is down
only one pawn but this position is
completely unplayable for black uh to
give you an example if you try anything
here let's let's try something like a6
attacking the rook you can just move it
and black still has no active moves
whereas white has as many active moves
as white wants for example if rook to f5
we go after the bishop we can just kick
away the rook rook has to go back
doesn't really matter where knight d for
then the knight comes to e6 attacks
everything the knight can never move
because well the b7 pawn falls we can
even capture it at any point and it's
just a terrible terrible position well
and uh on the other hand it's too easy
to play this with white like we said the
knight is coming to e6 you gain control
of f4 you can play king e3 push f4 you
can pretty much do anything and this
knight is not re-entering the game so
that's one way to do it another way
would be to play bishop to b6 uh just
you know play a waiting game uh block
the the rooks attacked it upon and also
now the bishop can't capture because the
knight guards it but still knight to e5
and what do you play here you could play
bishop b4 pick up this pawn so it's just
really really bad if rook to e8 going
after the knight we can even play knight
to d7 now attack the the bishop twice
and if bishop to d8
uh we we can't allow white to capture
the bishop because then the knight is
lost now we play knight to f6 again you
cannot eliminate it because then punk
captures with check and then we pick up
the piece and if rook to f8 then we play
bishop captures on b7 so nothing not
nothing to play here if you go for this
then we just grab two pieces and if rook
to f7 blocking we very happily go into
the same game captures captures 94 and
we have uh
we're up two points of course we are
completely winning here with white so of
course uh karaki knows this and after
bishop d5 he resigned the game and this
means that young shish of duda is the
winner of the fiji world cup 2021 uh and
he takes down sergey karjakin in the
classical time format which is something
very few people could do uh if you
remember not so long ago uh sergey
koryakin played a world chess
championship match against magnus
carlsen uh in new york and even magnus
was unable to
close the match in the
classical time format he had to go into
rapids against him but the duda gets the
job done in classical and uh he says all
right you had your chance with the white
pieces you you had your quick draw but
now i completely utilized my chance with
the white pieces and duda crushed uh
crushed a lot of very strong players
here uh just to
give you his four previous opponents uh
i mean extremely extremely strong so he
defeats uh karakin in the finals he
defeated magnus cross and in the
semi-finals he defeated vidit he
defeated grishchuk so uh duda just
obliterated everyone in this in this
tournament so huge huge congratulations
to him on this spectacular achievement
so we are going to see him in the next
video candidates tournament uh it's
going to be awesome karjakin will also
be there um
as he reached the the final so defeated
world cup and we'll see who else is
waiting for us there uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
we're gonna probably gonna check up uh
the the game between magnus and ferozev
uh for in in the clash for third place
as that also seems to be an interesting
one but uh we'll see how it goes so
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day and i
would like to thank david kimura tom
derelo alexander trebus brandon fukuda
and arnie cox for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing with probably one more game
from the world cup and then then we are
continuing the greatest saga of them all
uh see you soon